effectivement alors les salaires par
ordre croissant nous avons qu'il vit 223
1000 euros soprano 350000 euros
pascal obispo 500000 euros jennifer
600000 euros
florent pagny et marquer son affiche
florent payne qui est son cousin et
enfin mika 1 millions d'euros alors
choqué pas choquer alors un mashup pas
choquer alors que je fais pas choquer en
calories vous êtes choqués évidemment
enfin moi je conseillais attention
300000 euros ce qui me paraissait déjà
énoncées dans un fauteuil et julie notre
gîte les averses et toutes saisons
confondues évidemment s'il est plus là
allez-y oui bien sûr mais moi je me dis
que à ce stade ça devient simplement une
négociation financière est à dire quel
est l'intérêt de juger un petit jeune
avec une voix sympathique quand on
touche des sommes comme sa fin jeudi à
la fin on le sait mais contador
excusez moi c'est la première motivation
car et entre temps on fait quand tu fais
jury de the voice ou de bolts qui c'est
un braquage organisé en règle des six
mois de chute mais non mais t'es pas
chez toi et tu connais la tv quand même
déjà suis pas né dans le monde des
bisounours il s'est basé sur leurs
fauteuils
il écoute quand je termine à perdre on
sait bien que des gens qui viennent
faire le jury dans ce genre d'émission
ils viennent 1 pour prendre des sous
ensuite peut-être pour découvrir des
talents parce que ses deux jambes et à
la raison toutes les émissions du jury
croyez moi j'ai fait nouvelle star le
jury il prenait bulldozer ces congrès
mail le gcc pour eux voilà essayé a
qu'en france qu'on s'indigne serré
armant et puis et puis j'ai envie de
dire c'est une émission où le jury le
jury fait 60% de de l'importance de
l'importance de l'émission et s'il faut
mettre des gros sous pour avoir aidé un
de l'audience est bien le fond mais s'il
met se prélassaient de toute façon ils
sont gagnants mais en plus quand c'est
des artistes ou des animateurs est
toujours choqué par leur salaire et
causé des footballeurs
comment un peu par tout le monde est
choqué est-ce qu'il vient de ce que tu
dis carrosse et tu va renforcer le
sentiment des gens que comme tu fais de
la télé tu arrives tu poses ton cul ture
par cécile et d'alcan mais quand on
n'est pas le cas ici un mail art et
essai passe à la télé c'est pas arrivé
poser son cul raconter trois conneries
et partirai pas je n'approche les mêmes
très bien indivis c'est à moi que j'ai
inventé les chiffres tu vois ce que je
veux dire ces chiffres l'art que tpm
timbale pour venir ici de vos cultures
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on va pas nous change de sujet merci
beaucoup
vingt balles je retiens quand même
ah ah